the real men the real value men they
don't wear anything flashy you don't
even know they have money that's the
beauty they wear same t-shirt every day
and they're the true men with the values
they're the ones who they're dangerous
they they know their stuff and if they
want to inflict danger they know but the
beauty about them is that they have that
that that everything's under control so
if anyone wants to mess with them you
know you're gonna get burned but because
they're so in control and in their King
energy they they they the girls know
that he is a good person to be with
because he can protect me but he also
will respect me and love me